I always tell this story I teach a lot
at Harvard MIT all these places I'll
never forget it this guy puts up his
hand who hasn't contributed anything all
night he says listen I gotta ask you a
question I've been running this business
out of my dorm I'm making about 5
million a year in free cash flow my
fiancee came to me today and said that
she's going to leave me because I'm not
spending any time with her family I
don't have any time on weekends I just
can't because I'm so busy what do I do
now the class is like you could hear a
pin drop in there and I said to him wow
okay I'm not Dr Phil but let me give you
some advice here which one is easier to
replace
the girlfriend or the business
I mean you gotta ask that question